ja es ist natürlich so dass es eine
große
politikverdrossenheit gibt auch gerade
was die wahlen angeht ich habe es ja
jetzt auch erlebt in oberkrämer nicht
mal 50 prozent der menschen wollten
ihren bürgermeister wählen das hat sie
einfach nicht interessiert und es liegt
natürlich auch daran dass einfach die
politik politiker selbst die
bürgermeister oftmals den hierzu ihren
bürgern verloren haben es werden dinge
entschieden und die information darüber
was eigentlich
entschieden wird die es nicht
transparent genug es ist so ein
lippenbekenntnis dass man sagt ja auf
der internetseite blablabla dort da
steht ja alles aber welch ein normaler
mensch
findet das dann also ich nicht ich muss
immer meine freundin fragen sagt mal auf
welcher seite ich finde ich denn das was
jetzt geplant ist und wenn ich dann
gefunden habe dann lese ich einen
beamten deutsch das ich nicht verstehe
ich sagt er ist es jetzt gut und es ist
schlecht was meinen sie denn eigentlich
damit also dieser ganze
informationsfluss der ist schon mal sehr
schlecht und dann werden dinge
entschieden und dann stehen sie im
amtsblatt und da sagt man jetzt steht ja
alles im amtsblatt wenn es dann da
erstmal steht kann der bürger nichts
mehr dagegen tun und wenn er was tun
wenn er sich aufrafft umkämpft und sagt
ich möchte das verändern und eine
petition ins leben rufen dann sagen doch
die meisten interessiert uns nicht und
und das dann bürger irgendwann mal sagen
die politik interessiert mich das machen
die da oben ich habe kein einfluss ist
auch egal welche partei die klingeln da
etwas vor sich hin also ich bleibt zu
hause und geh nicht gehen und setzte
mich nicht ein das ist doch dann
selbstverständlich oder wenn sie
parteien wählen
aus protest
und das ist natürlich dann auch die
große gefahr dass sie dann parteien
wählen eigentlich nicht demokratisch so
große zustimmung ja die frage ist was
kann man machen könnte volksabstimmung
machen da wäre ich auf der kommunalen
ebene bei bestimmt ja und nein fragen
offen je komplizierter es wird schwierig
wir sehen es auch beim exit wo viele
sagen ich hätte doch anders entschieden
ich glaube am ende braucht es zwei dinge
um die politikverdrossenheit
kleinzukriegen erstens politiker
brauchen eine klare haltung mit klare
meinung auch parteien wenn du den
unterschied zwischen den parteien nicht
mehr erkennt gibt es protest und
einreduzieren protestparteien ja auch
wie die afd das zweite ist wirklich
heraus also das ist zwar nett hier in
berlin-mitte ja ich bin jetzt ja auch
über die friedrichstraße gekommen ist
alles gut und schön aber das ist
wirklich nicht die realität was wissen
wir das ist so und ich mache es halt so
habe ich von wolfgang bosbach gelernt
ich rufe jeden bürger in meinem
wahlkreis an der sich meldet oder
schreibe ihm eine e-mail mache ich
persönlich nicht irgendwie dass der
mitarbeiter schreibt viele grüße von der
lindemann und das stimmt gar nicht
sondern ich mache es nur in meinem
wahlkreis also jetzt nicht bitte ganz
deutschland
auf den abriss aber das funktioniert
dann haben die leute nicht nur das
gefühl man kümmert sich man weiß worum
es geht und das finde ich dass das
mindeste was man von abdullah öcalan
immer sagt natürlich jetzt nur die halbe
wahrheit denn mit der basis haben ja die
cdu politiker so ihre eigenen probleme
die basisbefragung jetzt die ja ihren
wunschkandidaten vor gewartet jetzt
sollen nur einmal gemacht werden
natürlich ausnahmsweise und nie wieder
also und ich finde übrigens auch mit
gute mit gutem grund ich bin ein großer
anhänger der repräsentativen demokratie
da wir haben die aus gutem grund
eingeführt und ich finde diese ganzen
debatten rund um die bürgerbeteiligung
aus meiner sicht dass
nebenkriegsschauplätze wenn wir eine
wirksame nachvollziehbare transparente
politik machen würden die nach einer
guten offenen debatte endet auch zur
entscheidung führt die kleine
kommuniziert werden brauchen wir nicht
alle zwei wochen unsere bürger anrufen
und fragen ob sie das oder das thema
haben wollen es ist natürlich auch
wirklich ein unterschied ob man die
bundespolitik nimmt oder auch eine große
stadt wie berlin oder ob man jetzt im
kommunalen bereich unterwegs ist da
finde ich sollte sollten die bürger auch
wirklich dort auch schon
bürgerbeteiligung finde ich auf ja da
gibt es viele maßnahmen das sind oft nur
lippenbekenntnisse das habe ich doch
ganz oft erlebt dann sagen wir ja und
hier ist jetzt die bürgersprechstunde du
hast drei minuten zeit deine anmerkung
zu machen und dann wird er wird ich hab'
ich habe ja was aufgeschrieben und dann
tragen die das vor mit dem mut eines
ganz normalen menschen und danach drei
mit uns so ja vorbei czisny haben wir
doch alles gemacht und da haben wir ja
informiert und da haben wir ja das läuft
ja alles und dann wird man mit einer
freundlichen arroganz abgefertigt das
habe ich sogar sie die man erst jetzt
das grundsatzprogramm für die cdu habe
mich würde interessieren was steht da
drin an basis beteiligung was steht dann
wirklich am ende drin für die
bürgerbeteiligung wenn es nach ihnen
ginge er linnemann nein bei den großen
komplizierten sachen gesehen dass beim
exit bei einer steuerreform bei einer
gesundheitsreform nein aber die
beteiligung auch der basis beim
grundsatzprogramm müssen wir viel mehr
machen bräuchten zum beispiel ich sag
mal wir haben ja solche ressourcen wenn
wir jetzt zum beispiel sagen jeder
müsste man ein paar angaben machen
natürlich freiwillig aber wir haben
jetzt ein problem in der schule
digitalisierung friedrich merz würde
sagen ich möchte gerne mal mit den 137
schulleitern reden
dienen die im parteibuch haben dann muss
das doch möglich sein und damit er auch
meine meinung bekommt wie das von
kultusminister kommen sie von dem mann
zu leuten ja aber wir müssen nicht mal
dieses es geht nicht weil du bist ja ich
meine in einem land leben wo war meine
idee hat loslaufen und die man umsetzen
ich sage nicht mehr geht nicht gibt es
nicht das ist so mein wahlspruch gewesen
und ich bin dazu politik eigentlich
bekommen durch den flughafen tegel eine
petition über 200 entstehen durch
christian lindner er kam später
nein also die fdp die hat er mich
gefragt ob ich nicht bei der petition
mitmachen will zum erhalt des flughafen
tegels weit über 200.000 unterschriften
gesammelt und wenn man einmal eine
petition als normaler bürger gestartet
hat dann weiß man was das für eine
arbeit macht auf fremde leute zuzugehen
könntest du hier unterschreiben und so
viele songs doch ab und lass mich in
ruhe denn nicht alle sind freundlich und
viele sagen nein unterschrift setzte ich
nicht runter ich bin ja dafür aber ich
unterschreibe hier nichts dann kriegt
man trotzdem so viele stimmen zusammen
und kein interessiert das ist doch schon
mal traurig es ist ja schon im vorfeld
traurig gewesen dass keiner gefragt
wurde ja wir machen da das überhaupt
hier mit den mit dem flughafen in
schönefeld da wurde schon im vorfeld
geklingelt ja okay wir schließen den es
wurde auch beispielsweise in berlin ja
auch nicht gefragt wie machen wir das
eigentlich wenn die deutsche wohnen
enteignet ist ja wo kommt das geld
eigentlich die 30 milliarden oder 35
wurde auch nicht es wurde nie gefragt
der bürger wurde nicht mit einbezogen
und wenn sie sich dann beschweren dann
okay war ja ned so sehe ich das im
großen und so sehe ich sie aber auch in
kleinen und ich es gilt bestimmt nicht
für alle bürgermeister es gibt bestimmt
auch welche die sind sehr nett mit ihren
bürgern aber zu oft erlebe ich es
einfach dass die bürgermeister die
verantwortung an die verwaltung
abschieben ja der ist für den bau
zuständig und jetzt dies da für soziales
und dies für familie und dann
verschieben das und kümmern sich nicht
selber wirklich persönlich um den bürger
und sein okay eure anliegen setze ich
hier bei meiner verwaltung durch ich
würde mal sagen die bürger sind
natürlich ein bisschen schizophren wir
wollen ja die daten nicht abgeben und
wir wollen uns nicht wirklich beteiligen
und wir kümmern uns nicht um die großen
politischen fragen und dann kommt
plötzlich eine pandemie und wir
unterschreiben überall brav unsere
unseren namen unsere daten geben die ab
damit würde tasse kaffee trinken können
also ich würde mir wünschen dass eine
lehre nach der partie auf jeden fall ist
wir müssen uns bürger wenn wir
mitgestalten wurden auch bereits an mehr
von uns wirklich preiszugeben ich finde
das ist dann müssen wir durch sonst gibt
es keine elektronische patientenakte
also keine wirksame wir sehen es ja
jetzt wieder hassel und das wäre für
mich auch eine form der
bürgerbeteiligung dass es auch eine
bringschuld der bürger ist dinge
natürlich preiszugeben wenn wir eine
bessere organisation des staates haben
wollen müssen wir das machen ob das
jetzt das parteibüro als lehrer ist bei
mir wahnsinn ohne hin alle sicherlich
nicht cdu insofern die frage haben wir
einen schon geklärt das weiß ich jetzt
nicht ob man das machen sollte aber wir
müssen auf jeden fall ehrlich mit und
sein und dann dinge auch preisgeben will
bessere organisiert also haben
organisationen haben und ich weiß zum
beispiel nicht wie robert habe jetzt
dieses klima geld auszahlen will über
welches format läuft das eigentlich klar
es gibt keine id für jeden bürger